il y a un an leur conjoint était abattu
dans une fusillade à moncton
aujourd'hui elles ont trouvé le courage
de venir s'adresser à la population
merci à tous ceux et celles d'ici et
d'ailleurs qui ont intérêt pour nous
vous nous avez aidés à voir la lumière
au bout du tunnel est à rebâtir nos vies
des centaines de citoyens s'étaient
rassemblés devant l'hôtel de ville pour
commémorer la tragédie
ils sont venus se souvenir du sacrifice
des trois hommes des pères de famille
parti à tout jamais nadine lorsque
l'épousé d'un des agents mort en service
et mère de trois enfants
toc demain dans mon coeur et je suis
fier d'honorer sa mémoire avec des
citoyens de martin rich ross attendait
un deuxième enfant au moment du drame
aujourd'hui ces petits garçons
participent sans trop comprendre ou
commémorations en auront leur père le
spectacle de chevaux de la grc une
activité familiale pour marquer l'heure
à laquelle la pareille date l'an dernier
les agents perdait la vie
angela gévaudan a choisi de ne pas y
aller plus tôt elle s'est confiée sur la
difficulté de l'épreuve à traverser
j'apprends des outils pour la capable de
demeurer un point coeur j'espère que
j'avais plus de cauchemars en pis
j'aurais pu céder x h parc
elle souffre du syndrome de stress post
traumatique
quand même que j'ai eu des gens de
symptômes si tu veux plus tôt
l'été dernier quand j'ai commencé à
perdre la mémoire puis prêtre capable de
vraiment faut que c'est comme ça ça a
commencé l'été dernier mais je pensais
que ça faisait partie de mon processus
de deuil une des autres choses qui a été
très important pour moi c'est de mettre
des limites parce que il ya eu beaucoup
d'événements qui ont été organisées d
ailleurs quand même beaucoup de choses à
faire encore décidé en appelant depuis
moi j'ai besoin de mon temps j'ai besoin
de mon temps pour m'occuper de moi même
participé à une cérémonie comme celle ci
est extrêmement douloureux pour elle
je pense que c'est intéressant quand
qu'on utilise le temps comme ça pour
marquer des choses c'est quand même les
gens ça fait un an ben c'est comme ça
que ça nous ramène dans le passé ou que
ça sert à srp je suis pas convaincu que
ces jeux peu convaincus que c'est une
bonne chose
difficile aussi pour les agents de la
grc
moi je suis fier de me manque comme je
ne peux pas je ne peux pas mettre des
mots là dessus aujourd'hui toute la
communauté s'est mobilisée pour
commémorer le tragique événement
mais aussi pour se créer de nouveaux
souvenirs en ce 4 juin ici marylène
marceau radio-canada moncton